as we exit 1917 and enter into 1918
we're getting into the final stages of
world war one and let's just give
ourselves a little bit of review a
little bit of background a little bit of
context the war started off as a
two-front war for the Central Powers you
have the Western Front you have the
Western Front right over here and you
had the huge you had the huge Eastern
Front right over here by 1917 the major
conflict on the Eastern Front
especially with Russia which was the
major power there had come to an end you
had a February revolution in Russia the
Tsar had to abdicate the throne you had
a provisional government then in
November of 1917 the Bolsheviks have a
coup they take over they have no
interest in prosecuting World War one
because they have their own civil war to
worry about so they say they sign an
armistice with the central powers by the
end of 1917 and then when we get into
1918 so let me write all this down so by
the time we get into 1918 they're ready
to sign a treaty in March in March the
Russians signed the Treaty of
brest-litovsk little visca which seeds
over all of this territory to the
Germans and takes the Russians out of
World War one so I'm not going to go
into detail in other videos but a huge
amount of territory and I'm going to do
it very informally right over here I'll
give a rough sense of of what where that
territory was and the treaty itself its
main significance because it treated in
last as you might already know the
Central Powers lost World War one so
that treaty was later nullified but the
the key importance of that treaty is one
it took Russia out of the war it allowed
the Central Powers especially Germany to
focus on the Western Front but the other
element of it is by giving so much
territory to the Germans the Germans
couldn't just you know leave that
territory as is if they wanted any
claims to it they had to devote some of
their troops to to occupy at least or at
least attempt to occupy some of it so
even though it was a huge opportunity
and the Germans did were able to after
the Treaty or even before the Treaty
they start were after the Armistice they
were a start they were able to start
bringing
more of the Eastern Front troops over to
the Western Front they didn't bring over
as many as they could have because they
left some to attempt to occupy some of
the territory that had been gained on
the Eastern Front but if you view things
from a German perspective at this point
March 1918 you're going to be feeling
pretty good you had you were you were
holding your own in a two-front war now
and you thought at one point you thought
Russia was the major threat there that
threat is gone you can now focus on a
one front war maybe you should be you
should be able to kind of put the
decisive blow against the Allies now and
that is how the Germans felt but they
were worried about a couple of things
they were worried about the the British
industrial capacity and the Allied
industrial capacity that was that that
was stronger than the Central Powers and
so the British could produce more tanks
and more guns and more weapons so it was
a race against that and there was also a
race against significant American entry
remember in April 1917 Woodrow Wilson
gives a speech to Congress they declare
war on the Central Powers and so the
Germans want to want to get this thing
over with before the Americans have a
chance to send in significant number of
fresh troops so in March 1918
not you not only do you have the Treaty
of brest-litovsk you also have the
beginning of German Germany's attempt to
deal that decisive blow to the Allies
and it's known as the spring offensive
so you have the spring the spring
offensive and the goal of the spring is
sense offensive was to was to
essentially try to end the war for the
Germans and they and the goal was to
separate the British from the French
forces the British for the most part
were in control of the line right over
here north of the Somme River while the
French were in control south of it so
the spring offensive especially the
first phases of the Spring Offensive in
march 1918 focused on this area right
over here
and at first it was actually very
successful they were able to make huge
territorial gains drive through the
lines drive the Allied powers back now
the problem was is that it wasn't a real
big strategic gain the Germans were just
hoping it would be such
demoralize ER that it would throw at
least maybe the French out of the war
and then maybe they could take care of
the British or whatever else but that
didn't happen and all of a sudden they
found themselves with these huge
territorial gains in very short amount
of time they had to supply themselves
they and and they didn't really quite
and it spread there their troops then
and so it frankly just led let the
opportunity arise for the Allies in
August to lead a counter-offensive and
this counter-offensive by the Allies is
referred to as a hundred days offensive
it began in August went roughly into
November so hundred days hundred days
offensive during which the Allies
between August and November were able to
push the Germans not only back beyond
what they had captured during the spring
offensive but all the way well back of
the of the front that was kind of the
stalemate line for most of World War one
and it was during this hundred days
offensive that to most objective
observers it was clear that the Allies
would win this war and it was clear to
several of the central powers or those
allied with the central powers as we go
into September as we go into September
of 1918 Bulgaria drops itself out of the
war just to remind ourselves where what
we're talking about so you have Bulgaria
right over here it Bulgaria right over
here it signs an armistice with the
Allies so we did you have Armistice I'll
use a little peace symbol for armistice
that's an armistice is just the fighting
has stopped you are you still in theory
it could be in a state of war so maybe I
shouldn't do the peace symbol I'll just
write armistice armistice armistice with
Bulgaria and this is really starting to
tighten the noose around the remaining
central powers because this this allowed
the Allies to gain control of Serbia and
of Greece which essentially tied tight
removed the last source of food for
austria-hungary and the German Empire
there was already a blockade the kind of
the harsh British blockade that we've
already talked about up in the North Sea
and so their last source of food was
from
the south but now with Bulgaria signing
an armistice and seeding over territory
now the the stranglehold was was was
really was really really coming into
effect now by October and remember at
this point it was reasonably clear and
even by this point even clearer to the
German people that the war is pretty
much done for and they're just waiting
for their leaders to to make it official
the several of the leaders of the German
Navy want to do this last-ditch what
could easily be considered suicidal
offensive against the British Navy and
as they're planning it and the the
sailors catch wind of it they mutiny
they revolt they say hey look the war is
over we're not going to die for a futile
and a futile attempt just kind of for
pride or whatever else and so you have a
naval mutiny begins naval mutiny and
eventually this spreads to the mainland
and leads to revolts and revolutions so
revolution in Germany in Germany and
this culminates in November in November
November 9th famous date in history
November 9 1918 you essentially the
kaiser wilhelm ii right over here let me
make sure you see them his picture this
is him right over here kaiser willem
wilhelm ii is forced to abdicate give up
his throne he flees to the netherlands
and in november ninth 1918 germany is
declared a republic so Germany no longer
no longer uh no longer has a king or an
emperor in charge Germany becomes a
republic and a little bit before this
November 3rd the writing was already on
right the writing was already clear to
the Austrians in fact they even in 1917
attempted to make some peace overtures
thinking that they were pretty much done
for but by November 3rd 1918 the
Austrians also signed an armistice
armistice armistice with the Austrians
with the Austrians and with the Kaiser
Wilhelm the second fleeing to the
Netherlands Germany becoming a republic
this sets up the armistice finally with
Germany on November 11th and this is one
of the most famous famous dates in
history known for a long time in the US
as Armistice Day and so was November
11th 1918 it was actually 11:00 a.m.
11:00 a.m. so you might remember the
famous the 11th hour of the 11th day of
the 11th month war or World War 1 or the
fighting in World War 1 was over with
the Allies victorious and the Central
Powers losing it and the terms of what
would happen for those that lost and
those that one would be dictated by the
Treaty of Versailles the Treaty of
Versailles in 1919 the terms of which
were finally finalized about six months
later so this is June you have the
treaty Treaty of treaty of Treaty of
Versailles which incidentally this is
like one of those little footnotes in
history the Americans did not actually
ratify it mainly because it had the
League of Nations in it which was this
you know which was this project of
Woodrow Wilson but the American people
and the American Congress was not a fan
of this whole you know transnational
Government League of Nations things so
the the United States did not ratify the
Treaty of Versailles but in effect on
Armistice Day November 11th 11:00 a.m.
the war was over Treaty of Versailles
dictated the terms many would argue
overly harsh terms of the treaty
Versailles and we're done with World War
one